i'm bill hemmer i'm dana perrino i'm
chris wallace and this is the fox news
rundown
friday december 10th 2021 i'm lisa brady
working has changed a lot during the
pandemic but a show that pays tribute to
the american worker is coming back with
the same message the best thing that the
show can do aside from just hopefully
entertain people
is
let me tap the country on the shoulder
as i like to do and say hey america
what about him what about her we speak
with the host of dirty jobs mike rowe
i'm chris foster 2021's been a violent
year in some cities with more shootings
and murders what we've seen here is this
kind of erosion both for the
classification of crimes as well as then
also the ability for law enforcement to
really and interdict because in many
cases their hands have been tied and i'm
joe koncha i've got the final word on
the fox news rundown
[Music]
thanks to the pandemic the u.s labor
force is one of the things that may
never be quite the same again a lot more
people working from home for instance
and many looking for new jobs more than
four million americans quit their jobs
in october close to september's record
as job openings also hover near record
territory at 11 million all indications
are that the economy in the fourth
quarter continues to grow robustly a
positive outlook from white house
economic adviser brian diese on thursday
that remains under debate in washington
as covid keeps coming up with surprises
so it may be the perfect time to get our
hands dirty
dirty jobs is back with a brand new
season and the incomparable mike rowe is
back as the host there's no scripting
there's no writing there's no actors
it's an honest look at work see
i'm doing something through the lens of
an honest day
strap in folks this one's going to be a
doozy
dirty jobs previously ran from 2005 to
2013 on the discovery channel the show
itself hasn't changed but the country
has i think
the new season premieres january 2nd on
discovery also streaming on discovery
plus we're still showing viewers a look
at an honest day's work through the eyes
of an apprentice
we still do virtually no pre-production
there's no actors there's no second
takes it's still a blisteringly honest
look
at the day i experienced
and that recipe still works what's
different i think is that our country is
just in this situation where
words don't mean what we used to think
they meant like essential for instance
essential work
really was the thing that appeared in
the headlines that
i think prompted so many people to reach
out and say mike
you did the the granddaddy of essential
working shows why don't you bring it
back and and just remind people of who's
keeping the lights on
i thought well why not it's been 10
years you know i mean i'm still sentient
i'm still upright i can still do it and
and people are still curious about the
jobs that make civilized life possible
for the rest of us
we are in the midst of a labor shortage
as we come out of the pandemic or at
least uh challenges with hiring shall we
say that are ongoing as someone who's
been a champion of the american worker
for so long does it feel like there's
been a paradigm shift to you or does it
feel like something less permanent well
i don't think it's binary i think in in
some places the shift has been
paradigm in nature and i think in other
areas we just haven't got the memo
the real question to me is what do 11
million open jobs
really mean like what does the existence
of all that opportunity actually say
and
it really depends who you ask you know
my my friends on the left say look that
many open jobs simply means that
employers are greedy and rapacious and
not paying a fair wage
my buddies on the right say that much
open opportunity simply means that human
beings are fundamentally lazy and
getting lazier
now i i don't know what the absolute
truth is i think there's probably a
little bit of truth in both areas and
someplace in the middle
reasonable people ought to be able to
meet but one thing's for sure
11 million open jobs is an inconvenient
truth to people who would tell us that
opportunity is dead
and so dirty jobs has always been an
opportunity for me to say
hey america you know look over here what
about him what about her
and once we get them looking and
thinking and hopefully laughing because
it's a it's a lighthearted show you know
then i can start to say and by the way
that welder covered in crap he's making
130 grand a year
that woman over there standing on that
factory line who looks like she like
lost a bet
guess what they're paying her you'd be
surprised and so the show can at its
best challenge some of the stigmas and
stereotypes and myths and misperceptions
that keep people from exploring these
careers
bringing the show back right now makes
makes a lot of sense because the country
does feel somewhat galvanized i think
more so than before
around this idea that wait something
something bad is happening regarding
opportunities something's wrong when 4.2
million people quit their jobs
and
so many companies are truly struggling
to to recruit it's not because they're
offering crap wages it's not because the
benefits are terrible something else is
afoot and it's not good
well yeah and maybe we're poised in
these strange circumstances to have
better matching between the
opportunities that are out there and
people who want opportunities and as you
say maybe need to look in different
places they hadn't thought of
you have kept very busy right through
the pandemic not just with your
foundation
but with the myriad other ways that
you've continued to shine a spotlight on
the american worker on essential workers
as you say this word essential that
people suddenly you know started paying
attention to
dirty jobs has a very loyal fan base
though have you have you been hearing
from a lot of fans oh yeah
yeah i mean
the thing is about dirty jobs the the
most strange and rewarding and alarming
thing
is that it's a totally unscripted
non-fiction show and those shows
don't hold up in reruns
right something happens in a non-fiction
show you see it once and you're it's
done
dirty jobs we we went out of production
in 2012 but it never went off the air
it's aired every week sometimes every
day some it still airs like nine ten
times in a row on on the weekends
and so
there's a hunger uh for something in
that show and it's not me you know i
mean i i'd like to think i'm not in the
way of it but there is something so
basic
the truth is lisa it's not really a show
it's a mission it's a trip and i'm not
really a host i'm a i'm a guest and the
promise from the beginning from episode
one
was look i i don't know what's under the
rock but i'm gonna take a look the
network gave me some money i got some
jet fuel i got a crew
and you're invited to come along let's
see what work looks like one day at a
time through the eyes of an apprentice
and that's what it's been from the start
and so viewers
really responded to that and they
actually programmed the show for me
it's the viewers that are that are
really the host of the show because the
people who we feature watch the show and
they're the experts it's the viewers who
program the show
my job really is just to
stay out of the way
right and and and be honest don't do a
second take second takes are
performances and the audience can smell
that
the feedback has been constant the
encouragement to get it back on the air
was daily and i have no idea what we did
six hours um it was just a modest bite
just kind of putting my toe back into
the filthy end of the pool and we'll see
what people think but i
i'm guessing they're gonna dig it i know
part of the focus for this reboot is
things we rely on but don't really think
about like bridges sure um
and i mentioned bridges in particular
because that especially is something
where you're only seeing the outside of
a bridge not even all the intricate
details on the inside
um
is that a premise that you already had
in mind no well it's a it's a great
metaphor you know building a bridge is
something that you know has to happen
right now in every imaginable sense in
this country we need to build bridges
between
blue and white collar left and right
both sides of the aisle i mean
we don't really build a bridge this
season on the show but the first episode
we do feature a construction job that i
didn't get to in the last round which is
rod busting these are iron workers and
we are working on an overpass which i
guess is a bridge right
and um i spent a day with these guys and
you talk about a band of brothers man
the these this is the toughest
construction job i know of because all
day long they're just hauling
and twisting and tying rebar long
strands of thick iron and they build
these elaborate
skeletons and these super structures and
if you see an overpass
just roughed out with rebar
it takes your breath away it's so
beautiful and so
tangible and so and so masculine right
this is this all of this iron
and then the most extraordinary thing
happens
the concrete guys come in
and they cover it all up
and all of this art and all of this work
and all of this sweat that takes to
to build the guts of a bridge
becomes utterly invisible
to the people who use the bridge and the
people who look at the bridge
and so i'm very interested in in
spending time with those men because
every single day
they know what they do they know how
hard it is they know how critical it is
but virtually no one else does
so
the best thing that the show can do
aside from just hopefully entertain
people
is
let me tap the country on the shoulder
say hey america
what about him what about her what about
them for anyone who doesn't know you're
also an amazing singer
well opinions very but thank you
and you even have a christmas song
santa has a dirty job
um shot right to number one on itunes
charts after its fox and friends debut
how did you end up working with john
rich on that so funny yeah he's got a
show on fox called the pursuit and he
called me one night and said hey mike
remember last time i saw you down there
in nashville we had a pretty good time
right and i said yeah we had a great
time why don't you come on my show i'd
like to interview micro he can't call me
mike i'm just i'm mike rowe right so i
said sure so i'm sitting on his show and
we're having a pretty good time and
we're talking about sad songs so we were
swapping notes and he said micro you
know what we ought to
we ought to do a christmas album one day
and i said yeah we could do you know a
dirty take on carol's or something he
goes you know he's got a dirty job santa
claus got a dirt job and then he goes in
the bathroom during a break and he comes
out of the bathroom and he's recorded
the chorus
on his iphone santa claus got a dirty
job santa claus got a dirty job santa
claus got a dirty job and he does it all
night long now while he's singing this
he's doing what he's what he would do in
the bathroom right so i i'm just
listening to it laughing saying dude you
wrote a song while you were using the
toilet of course i'll record it with you
so we went to nashville he called the
oak ridge boys we all got together and
we sing the song
last week it was the most downloaded
song in the world
and uh
all the money that comes from it goes to
my foundation and his we split it down
the middle he's got a great charity
called folds of honor that takes care of
scholarships for families of vets guys
women who didn't come home
and and i got microworks so you know
each year we try and do a different kind
of fundraiser
and
this is one of those things i had no
idea i was just minding my own business
doing an interview and the next thing
you know i'm in a recording studio and
now we got a hit so you just trip and
fall into wonderful things it's kind of
what you do sometimes the things are
wonderful and sometimes uh it's you know
feces from another species but you know
what you take the good with the bad
micro host of dirty jobs which returns
to the discovery channel january 2nd
also streaming new and original episodes
on discovery plus thank you so much
always a pleasure thanks for it's nice
to see you in person yes you're in the
studio what an honor
[Music]
this is joe koncha with your fox news
commentary coming
up with three weeks left in the year
annual murder records are already broken
in at least a dozen big cities
philadelphia has had more than 500
murders the most there since 1990.
portland oregon's had the most since
1987 austin texas the most since 1984.
there's also albuquerque baton rouge
columbus indianapolis louisville st paul
tucson toledo and rochester new york
other cities had records broken the year
before and gun violence in general has
been higher nationwide you know it is a
convergence of a number of factors in my
view
even we go before coving bill daley is a
former fbi investigator and
international security consultant kind
of pre-coveted we had kind of momentum
by kind of liberal and state legislative
groups and branches uh to reduce
classifications of crimes and i say this
because sometimes when you reduce lower
end crimes it gives rise to higher end
crimes that's the old kind of broken
window theory you know if you let a
broken window remain broken you know
people get in they break into whatever
the facility is they commit other crimes
much like even going back to
uh with some of this even receiving stop
and frisk were in major cities they
would stop people from going uh using
turnstiles to jump over them and they
would arrest those people sometimes
catch them with guns and they would stop
other crimes from happening
but we've seen here is this kind of
erosion both by the classification of
crimes as well as then also the ability
for law enforcement to really and
interdict because in many cases their
hands have been tied uh so you look at
things such as as guns being perhaps
more readily available on the streets or
gun crimes we've seen some really um
atrocious and really impactful images of
shootings caught on video of of people
being shot in the street uh so guns are
out there being used more and more and i
think also combined with what happened
during cobra and some of the perhaps
kind of the self-instilled constraints
on police uh because of concerns over
the allegations of of abuse or or being
in any way kind of racially
discriminatory there have been kind of a
perhaps a recoiling which has resulted
in this gap being filled by these
criminals and unfortunately as i said it
starts from the lower end crimes and
we've seen those certainly over the past
year that lead up into the more horrific
you know homicides and other murders
that take place um do you know is are
there more guns on the streets or fewer
guns being taken off the streets if you
get my meaning
um i'd probably say
it's probably worthy the latter where
there's there's less being taken off the
streets but those are being backfilled
also uh by more coming into the market
so if you're not taking them off the
inventory of those guns being in the
in the population those those let's say
illegal weapons in the population uh are
going up uh because people are not being
stopped they're not you know being
there's no major interdiction going on
aside from maybe some uh some federal
interdiction from
uh atf and some other authorities but on
a local level uh they're finding their
ways in and around major cities uh
finding ways in the hands of of miners
and i would say you know it's because
they're not being taken off the street
uh it's allowed the inventory of those
weapons to propagate uh and with new
weapons coming into the mark into the
street and onto the black market it's
allowed people who in the past may not
have had access to them now have access
you mentioned stop and frisk um there's
another also kind of growing movement
about bail reform we don't necessarily
want innocent people being harassed you
know the crime of walking while black is
a term um we don't necessarily want
innocent people who can't afford to get
out on bail rotting
in county for
six months or whatever just because they
can't afford it it's a really tricky
balance
yeah and the thing about bail reform so
you know i think it's important for us
you know we're having this discussion to
kind of talk about how this all comes
about because you know as much as we do
focus on perhaps more liberal district
attorneys uh state attorney generals
these in many cases are driven uh the
bail reform act and and even sentencing
guidelines are driven by again the
legislative bodies they're the ones who
make the laws they're the ones who make
the laws in in our country whether uh in
the federal or the state level and those
are the ones also providing kind of the
guidelines for for bail i was just
speaking with a uh a judge here in in
new york uh not too long ago about this
and as much as they would like to you
know put a higher bail
on certain violations they're limited
by what has been passed down by by the
state governments by the legislative
branch and so i think i think what's
happening here is we're seeing people
who are out there they know
they know the law they know if they're
they steal under a certain amount of
money they're not going to be prosecuted
uh but again that just i think kind of
encourages other people to say hey
here's a gap that needs to be filled and
they fill it with with criminal acts
whether it be on the lower end or as i
said before many of those then kind of
lead up to
other types of crimes where either gangs
are shooting each other because of turf
issues or attacking citizens themselves
let's talk about those smash and grab
crimes
they're high profile the surveillance
videos is um
provocative for lack of a better word um
what's happening here is it coordinated
is it organized gangs is it
one group or a small group saying
seeing it on tv and hearing that it's
successful and saying geez we could do
that too that's some easy money
uh and you've worked with businesses on
theft prevention a lot what's happening
here right
you know
kind of we all go back uh just a few
years ago kind of at the rise of
social media
um and where people would have these
flash mobs would come out and start to
dance and do other things but then all
of a sudden it took a a very sad and
tragic turn where they kind of these
mobs would show up you know to go and
pilfer things and stake things from
stores this is just a minute of the
manifestation of it i think if we kind
of claw behind the scenes we're going to
see that these are are coordinated uh
they're coordinated on a lower kind of
grassroots level people getting together
saying hey if we all go up and show in
moss into some you know uh high-end
retail uh and we go out and we each take
one one handbag or two handbags uh
depending upon wherever the jurisdiction
is and the uh
kind of that that cut off or being
prosecuted uh we can do it and so it is
this kind of coordinated um wouldn't say
is coordinated from what we may have
seen in the in the kind of older days of
organized crime per se when we had mafia
other uh being out there doing these
things but this is another another
manifestation of it so it is coordinated
and it is something that
you know retailers are really faced with
they're faced with the issue of of how
to protect their their property their
inventory their premises and their
employees um while at the same time
trying to be open for those other
customers who want to come into a
high-end store and shop so uh they're
really faced with that balance between
kind of security and safety and
preventing these kinds of incidents from
happening how can you i mean what do you
possibly do i mean if you're overwhelmed
by
you know four six eight a dozen people
coming in with hammers or bats or bricks
or whatever the people working in retail
aren't going to help you probably one
security guard's not going to help you
no no no that's why these are more
incidents that that are
impacted or were occurred because of the
larger issues we just talked about here
where people are not being prosecuted
but there's no deterrence where they see
other people getting away with it
there's no bail or they're back out
there so retailers are really are really
kind of stressed with how they protect
their employees how they protect their
assets is that limiting the number of
things that are out there in the counter
and all the things that are stored
behind in more secure areas where it's
more difficult to get it takes more time
to get to uh there are some things that
perhaps they could consider but
the the real issue here uh is the fact
that it's it's occurring and it's
incurring because people are being
encouraged uh to do it because of of not
being prosecuted uh of these limitations
on you know what they'll get as far as
no bail no no prosecution maybe a desk
appearance ticket um you know if they so
decide to show up a desk appearance
ticket after they're actually caught
so it does go back to these more
fundamental issues we just talked about
a few minutes ago
if this is a legislative issue a
judicial issue
um what about the law enforcement side
the justice department for example
spending i don't know
many many many millions of dollars in
grants and other programs to to get more
police officers on the streets locally
is this a problem the the gun violence
and the retail stuff that you can
effectively throw cops at
well i i i think yeah the the sure the
short answer is yes and i think we have
seen you know that pendulum of kind of
defund the police
swinging back slightly and i say that
because even just the other day out in
in oakland california which many might
consider can be a bastion of liberalism
but in oakland california with a surge
in in crime and killings they're now
looking to hire more officers so hiring
more police have more police presence on
the street
is is one thing um the the other part of
this is not so much the police you know
out there it's the police being able to
do their job um and because police said
before in the past we're able to stop
kind of lower end criminals whether it's
those turnstile jumpers who were caught
and they were wanted for something or
they had a gun on them you know without
them being able to interdict on the on
those kind of minor crimes with uh with
not being accused of being
discriminatory or being abusive in any
way um is that you know the more police
on the street provides a certain level
of deterrence but if they have no kind
of clout they have no ability to be able
to kind of interdict uh you know really
it's uh it makes us feel good but it's
not going to do anything uh and so that
deterrence needs to be there from the
from the get-go but yes more police
officers
good sign good sign that places like
oakland want to be um be more engaged in
hiring police officers and perhaps that
pendulum will defund the police maybe
going back the other way just because
people say you know what more can we do
we need to get more more presence on the
street at least from a a broader
deterrence perspective even if the hands
are a bit tied
from a criminal justice standpoint
bill daley former fbi investigator uh
after his career of the bureau he's had
a very successful second career uh as a
security consultant uh bill always good
to talk to you thank you very much
thanks very much have a good day
[Music]
jason in the house the jason chaffetz
podcast dive deeper than the headlines
in the party lines as i take on american
life politics and entertainment
subscribe now on
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you
download podcasts
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
joe koncha what's on your mind as you
may have heard we live in a media age
where the race of the defendant and or
the victim plays a major role in media
coverage we saw it in waukesha wisconsin
where many outlets moved on quickly from
that christmas parade massacre that left
children and grandmothers dead seemingly
because the race of the suspect didn't
jive with the desired narrative of
traditional media the kim potter trial
if precedent is any indicator will be
largely seen through the prism of race
let's preview this trial potter is white
the man killed dante wright was black
there was a warrant out for his arrest
he did appear to resist arrest potter
thought she was reaching for her taser
instead it was her gun fortunately there
is body cam footage complete with audio
so you can hear her genuine shock that
she used her gun instead of her taser
less ambiguity it's always a good thing
still this is minneapolis tensions are
still high given the george floyd case a
black lives matter activist for example
has been arrested and charged with
attempting to intimidate the judge the
jury is also mostly white which if
potter is acquitted will be blamed for
making a wrong decision again through
the prism of race and that's unfortunate
and dangerous maybe a police officer
with no prior record of controversy made
a terrible mistake maybe she should have
known the difference between a taser and
a gun and she should be held accountable
given a life was lost if a jury thinks
she should but no matter it'll be race
race race because our media is a
one-trick pony on the matter i'm joe
koncha
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe
button to get more of the news and
opinion you trust and click the fox news
rundown playlist for the latest episodes